hi in this module i'm going to talk
about the back propagation algorithm for
computing gradients automatically
it's generally associated with training
neural networks but it's actually a far
more general algorithm
so let's begin with our motivating
example which is suppose we're doing
regression with a four layer neural
network
so remember that we
do the loss on a given example
the loss with respect to a particular
example
and now we have the weights
of the network
v1 v2 v3 and w
is equal to
and remember the form of the neural
network you start with a feature vector
you multiply it by some weight matrix
that gives you a vector you send it
through the activation function
repeatedly apply it apply a
matrix
send it through an activation function
um the left multiplied by a matrix
center through an activation function
you take the final vector you take the
dot product with respect to the final
weight vector and that gives you your
score
so this is your prediction
subtract
the target value and you square it that
gives you your loss
so now if you wanted to train this
neural network using stochastic gradient
descent you would need to
compute the gradient of this loss
function with respect to each of the
parameters so for example
would compute the gradient of the loss
with respect to v1 that gives you a
gradient update which you can then use
to update v1 same with v2
3
and w
so now you can sit down with this lovely
expression
and you can just grind through the map
and get the expressions it's
straightforward but it's rather tedious
another question is how can you get the
gradients without all doing all this
manual work
so the answer to that is computation
graphs
so here is our loss function again
and what we're going to do is
write down the computation graph for
this mathematics computation graph is a
direct acyclic graph whose root node
represents the final expression this
loss function
and each node
represents intermediate sub expressions
like one v of x for example
now what this computation graph is going
to allow us to do is
allows us to apply the back propagation
algorithm to the computation graph and
automatically get gradients out
so there's two purposes actually that
we're going to do this the first is
computing the gradients automatically
and this is how deep learning packages
like tensorflow and pi torch work behind
the hood
and second more of all
we're going to use this as a tool to
gain insight into the modular structure
of the gradients and try to demystify
because taking gradients by hand you can
lead it into situations where you just
have a lot of symbols
but using a graph we can start to
see the structure
okay so our starting point is
to think about functions as boxes so
imagine you have this
expression a plus b
and that gives rise to some variable c
so i'm going to represent this as a very
simple computation graph where you have
a
and b
and these arrows point into this
box that does plus
and the result will be labeled as c here
okay
so
now the question is
if i change
a or b by a small amount how much does c
change oh this is just a notion of a
gradient
so informally we can look at this as
a
plus b equals c
now if i go and fiddle
with a a little bit i add epsilon
so what happens to the right hand side
well on the right hand side i just get
plus one epsilon
and what i'm gonna do so the gradient of
c with respect to a
is one
i'm just gonna write it on that
so this can be
interpreted as kind of amplification or
gain if i move a by l a little bit this
is kind of the multiplicative factor
that c needs to be by
so let's do the other side so a
uh plus b and you add a bit of noise to
b
and again you get one plus epsilon so
the gradient of c with respect to b is
one as well
here's another example of c equals a
times b
so as a computation graph a
and b
go into this box which uh takes the dot
product
and you get c
so
what happens uh
when you add epsilon noise to a
a plus epsilon times b
is equal to c
plus
and now you have b epsilon coming out so
therefore the gradient of c with respect
to a is now b
and analogously
we add the voice to b and we see that
the
the contribution to the output c is a
times epsilon a epsilon
okay therefore the gradient over here is
a
okay so this all should be kind of
familiar i just cast the sum and product
rules for differentiation
in graphical form
so let's do a few more kind of small
examples these small examples are going
to be the building blocks it turns out
that you can take these building blocks
and compose them to build all sorts of
more complicated functions
so here's the example we saw before a
plus b
and the gradients are one and one
a minus b
the gradients are 1 and minus 1 because
if you add epsilon to b
then
this difference is going to go down by
epsilon
here we saw this example a
times b
and the gradients are b and a
um if you look at the squared function a
squared
the gradient with respect to input is 2a
so
the kind of power rule
um let's consider a and b
where you take the max
okay so this one
uh let's think about this so if i add a
little bit of
add epsilon to a
how's that going to change the max
well
if a is greater than b
then it's just going to
change the max by epsilon
but if a is less than b then it's going
to be
0 because b is going to be
um so the gradient
of this max of a and b with respect to a
is the indicator function of whether a
is greater than b or not
and symmetrically
the gradient with respect to b is
whether b is greater than a
okay
and finally here is the logistic
function
a
uh sending it through this logistic
function
and a little bit of algebra which i'll
spare you of produces that's actually a
quite elegant expression which is sigma
times one minus
and you can kind of check
that as a goes to
infinity or minus infinity
remember the the sigmoid is going to
saturate at one or zero which means this
gradient is actually going to go to zero
so that's just a simple sanity check
okay so these are the basic building
blocks
and that's really all the the kind of
the um
uh brute force differentiation that
we're gonna really do the rest is just
composition
so so now we take these building blocks
and we put them together so here's a
simple example so suppose you take a
square you get b
and then you take b and you square it
and you get c
so
by the
building blocks from the previous slide
we know that the gradient
on this edge is going to be 2
times input here which is b
and the gradient along this edge is
going to be 2 times
a
okay so now using ts2 we can apply
chain rule from calculus to compute the
gradient
of c with respect to a
and this is going to be nothing more
than just the product of those two
quantities
so in this case we get 2b times 2a
and remember that
b is equal to a squared
subset that 2 that in you get 4 8 cubed
and remember
c is a to the fourth so we can verify
that this is indeed consistent with
using the power rule
okay
so in general
you can take
compute these gradients by simply taking
the product along edges
and that's going to be really useful
um
on this slide okay so now let's turn to
our first example
um
the hinge loss for linear classification
we actually did this one before but i
just want to do it again through the
lens of computation graph so here is a
loss function
and given this loss function i'm going
to construct the computation graph and
then compute the gradient
of the loss with respect to w
so working bottom up we have
the weight
vector and we have the future vector and
we take the dot product that gives us a
score
we take the score we take y and multiply
them together and that gives us the
margin
1
minus the margin
and you take the max of that
and 0 and you get the loss
so another nice thing about the
computation graph is it allows you to
annotate these sub expressions and see
how the computation and what the pieces
are
okay so now let us compute the gradient
of the loss with respect to w
and what i'm going to do here
is all i need to do is compute the
gradients along all these edges
from
loss down to w
okay so let's begin at the top here
so the gradient width and oh here is our
cheat sheet
don't forget the cheat sheet
so we just now pattern match here's a
max over two things well what's on this
edge it's first thing
greater than second thing okay so
the gradient here is going to be first
thing which is one minus margin greater
than the second thing which is zero
and now what about this edge so here is
minus one so let's have minus one
what about this uh times so times is the
second input second input
and the second input here is y
and here's another times the second
input is f of x
so
this allows us to think about the
gradients one piece at a time and all
the little edges are just
implications of this cheat sheet here
okay now we're ready to read off the
gradient
of the loss with respect to w
and this is just going to be product of
all
the
edges
okay so we have
first we have
one minus margin greater than 0 so
that's
i'm going to rewrite that as margin less
than one
verify that's the same thing
but we have a minus sign here
that's a minus sign here
and then we have
y and then we have phi of x
you multiply them all together and
that's the expression and you can verify
that
this is indeed
the gradient of the loss function
so in summary
we computed from uh computed the
computation graph
and then we apply the this cheat sheet
to the individual edges and then you
just multiply them all together
and just as another note
remember the gradient
with respect to w is really
think about perturbations if you change
w by a little bit how much is a loss
going to change
and the change is going to be the
product of all these kind of
amplifications
evaluated at a particular
point
all right so now let's do neural
networks now
um so this is not going to be really
anything new it's just going to be a
different example
so i'm going to do a two-layer layer
neural networks
and we're going to again build this
computation graph up
so we have the feature vector
you have the first layer weight matrix v
you take the product
and then you stick this through the
activation function and we're going to
label that h
which is the hidden uh
hidden vector
and now we're going to take the dot
product of w and h that gives you
the score
and then now it's a score
minus y
is a residual and the residual square is
a loss
okay
another aside is that the computation
graph really allows you to see visually
this modularity so the part up here
is just
the square loss
and the part down here is anything
any way of computing
any way of computing a score
so before we had a linear classifier a
class linear predictor now we have a
two-layer neural network it could be a
four-layer neural network which
this computation graph is just
okay so that's a computation graph now
let's uh
to perform stochastic gradient descent
we need to compute the gradient with
respect to both w
and v
okay so let's compute the gradient with
respect to w of the loss
and
what i'm going to do is
look at the
the edges and could be the gradients
okay so here's our cheat sheet um so
okay what goes on this edge what's the
gradient of the square
this is just two times the input which
is in this case two times residual
um
what about this edge
so um
minus so this should just be a one
on here
and then what about this edge uh this is
just going to be the second input um
right here so that is an h
okay
so now multiply all these things
together and you get the gradient
of um
the loss function with respect to w
okay
all right um
so
one thing you can um kind of double
check is that we did do the gradient of
the square lots for linear predictors
and it was also two times the residual
times the feature vector instead of
h
and now we just have h which is a kind
of a stand-in for
the feature vector with
as far as w is concerned
so that's kind of a nice sanity check
all right so now let's do this more
complicated one so this we want to
compute the gradient with respect to v
of loss of
all the arguments
and this equals
um let's fill in all the edges um
so first of all notice that
these two
uh edges are actually in common with
this path
so we can go ahead and write them down
so one cool thing about computation
graphs is it allows you to see
the shared structure that the gradients
are actually have themselves also have
common sub expressions
okay so now we need to do more work here
so the gradient on this edge is going to
be
the other input which is w
um this is
sigma so the gradient is going to be
sigma the input minus 1 minus
sigma
so this is going to just be h
times 1 minus h
this
this hollow circle here represents the
element product of a vector so you just
take two vectors and you multiply the
elements together
and this is because this
function is applying just element-wise
and then what about this final
edge this is just going to be p of x
which is just other input
and now we can just multiply the rest of
these things together so we have w
times
uh h times y minus h
times a fee of x
transpose
so there's a slight kind of uh annoyance
here because here we have v times v of x
whereas before um there's no transpose
here because we just have w dot
something and w dot is the same as w
transpose okay so
uh but the the high level is that
the product of all of these green pieces
yields the gradient
of the loss with respect to v
okay
all right so that
finishes up this example
so now
we have mainly used this graphical
representation to visualize the
computation of function
values using gradients
but you know the promise of back
propagation is that we didn't have to do
any of that at all i just did that to
kind of illustrate
the the inner workings of
radiant computations on the computation
but now we're going to introduce a batch
propagation algorithm which is a general
procedure for computing these gradients
so we never have to worry about it
i'm going to do this back propagation
for a simple example which is just this
squared
loss and linear regression
and one note is that
previously we've worked with uh
symbolic expressions but the actual
algorithm is going to operate on numbers
usually
so what i'm going to do is work with a
concrete example and walk the through
the back propagation algorithm with this
example
so the back propagation algorithm
includes two steps a forward uh step and
a backwards step
so in the forward step what we're going
to do is we're going to compute a bunch
of forward values
from the leaves to the root
and each forward value is simply the
value of that sub expression rooted at i
the value could be a scalar a vector or
a matrix
so let's walk through this example here
okay so at the leaves we have um w which
is three one
and we have the feature vector one two
so now if you take um
these two quantities
and you
multiple take the dot product
you get three plus two which is
five
um and now you take the score five and
you take y
you subtract them
and you get the residual which is three
notice that the forward values of this
node is five and the four value of this
node is three
and now finally you
square this
and the value of the square is uh
3 squared which is 9.
or value at this node is
okay so now we're done with a forward
phase all we've done is evaluated
uh the loss
but importantly we have also remembered
all the values along the way which will
become come in handy
so now the backward step is we're going
to compute
a backward value
gi 1 for every node
and this is going to be
the gradient of the loss with respect to
the value at that node if that node
changes value how does the loss change
so the backward pass is going to compute
the values from the root to the leaves
so let's do this first of this example
so the base case
gradient of the loss with respect to
loss is one
um
and now
we
look at the gradient on this edge we did
this before it's just two times the
residual
okay so now
um we need to compute the backward value
of this node
okay to do that
we're going to take
the backward value of the parent and
multiply whatever is on this edge what's
on this edge is two times the residual
the residual is three
so it's two times three which is six
and so one times six is six
notice that in computing this backward
value i'm using
the intermediate computations for the
from the forward pass
okay so let's continue
so the gradient on this edge is 1.
so backward value here is
6 which is the parent backward value
times what's on this edge which is 1
that gives us 6.
and then the backward value of this node
is 6 times what's on this edge which is
this other input one two
and that gives us six comma
so to conclude the back complication
algorithm takes these concrete values
this expression
and produces the gradient of the loss
with respect to w evaluated at these
concrete values and that's 6 comma 12.
okay
and the math propagation algorithm
remember works for any computation graph
four layer neural networks
much more complicated models but this is
just a simple example to show you the
dynamics of forward pass
and backward
pass okay so now we have the back
propagation algorithm we compute
gradients we stick these gradients into
stochastic gradient descent and then we
just
run scans the gradients in and then we
get some weights
um so now one question is
uh
what do we get um so we
wanted to optimize the training loss
using stochastic gradient descent
but running stochastic ingredients in
does it actually minimize this weight
this is a little bit of a delicate uh
question here
so
for linear predictors
it turns out that the training loss for
a complex loss is going to be a convex
function
which
means that it is going to have a single
global
minimum
which means that if you start at some
point and then you just follow your
nodes by running gradient set with
appropriate step size it's going to
converge to the goal law optima
but for neural networks
the training loss is non-complex
and which means that
there's no guarantees at all that you're
going to converge to the global minimum
you're lucky you can convert to a local
mill
so optimization of neural networks is in
principle hard
but
of course people do it anyway and you uh
actually get some
good results
so that there's a gap between theory and
practice which is uh not quite
understood yet
but in practice um
getting neuronal works to train properly
is a little bit of art so i think of it
as kind of like driving stick there's
just a lot of
degrees of freedom you can stall and get
stuck but if you know what you're doing
you can actually get a lot of good
results okay
so here are some examples just to give
you a flavor of what needs to be done
okay so here is a 200 network and here
is the loss function
um the first is
initialization matters so if you have a
convex function wherever you initialize
you run it for long enough you converge
to that global optimum
for a non-convex function if you
initialize here you might get stuck up
here if you initialize over here you'll
get stuck here and so on
so generally you have to be a little bit
careful about how
you initialize um you can't initialize
at zero
because all it turns out that all the
rows of your
play matrix are going to be identical
which is not very useful
um so you temporarily initialize around
zero with some amount of random noise or
you can use pre-training to initialize
uh your network as well
which we won't cover right now
um
another
thing that people do is called over
parameterization so here this
corresponds to adding more hidden units
than you kind of really need
this corresponds to having more a lot of
rows of this uh of this matrix
and the idea here is that
the more
hidden units you have the more kind of
quote-unquote chances you have
of
having the network learn something
reasonable by your data so some of the
units might die off and not be very
useful but
you know maybe like some fraction of
them will actually be useful
and the final
thing that people do is using adaptive
step sizes which is generally an
extension of stochastic gradient descent
remember as the caster grain is said you
have
we had a single step size ada which
controlled how fast you move
with methods like atograd or atom you
actually get a uh per features uh or per
uh parameter step size so for every
weight you get a number which dictates
how fast you should be moving in that
direction
and this generally leads to better
results
okay so one maybe high level thing to
keep in mind is
don't let your gradients vanish or
explode so
um if i explain this it will become kind
of clear so when you run gradient
descent or gradients the cascading
descent
if your gradients vanish which means
become
too small or close to zero then you
won't make you'll get stuck and you
won't make progress
but your gradients become too large
then you'll just explode and you will
oscillate and
might diverge
so
with careful initialization and setting
up the step sizes generally uh and even
designing of the neural uh network
architecture
all of this is around kind of making
sure that your gradients don't vanish or
explode
okay so that's all the guidance i'll
provide you there's a lot more to be
said on this topic we're just kind of
giving you a
high level overview
okay so let's summarize now so
the most important topic of
this module is that of a computation
group
this allows you to represent arbitrary
mathematical expressions and these
expressions are built out of these
simple building blocks and i hope that
this car the idea of computation graphs
will allow you to get a better visual
understanding of what your mathematical
expressions are doing and also what
gradient computations are about
and
then we saw we had a back propagation
algorithm which is this general purpose
algorithm for leveraging the computation
graph to make uh compute the gradients
so notice that
we've done this kind of in the context
of neural networks but i stress that
computation graphs and back propagation
is fully general it allows you to handle
many many functions
and the generality
is one of these reasons that you can
allows you to iterate very quickly on
new types of models and loss functions
and
opens up this new paradigm for model
development
differential programming which we'll
talk about in a future module
all right that's it thanks